dos estados uno israelí y otro palestino
fue la solución que otra vez propusieron
joe biden y mahmud abás sin un plan
aunque el presidente estadounidense
apeló desde belén al sufrimiento y la
desesperanza del pueblo palestino sin
nombrar la ocupación israelí admitió que
el terreno no está listo para una paz en
su lugar anunció ayudas adicionales de
200 millones de dólares para la agencia
de la onu que se dedica a los refugiados
palestinos y otras de 100 millones para
la red de hospitales de jerusalén este
que son clave en la atención de
pacientes palestinos de jerusalén este
cisjordania ocupada y también caza
además recibió una promesa que los
palestinos han escuchado de otras
administraciones sin verla cumplida por
israel y es instalar una red de internet
móvil que sea efectiva en los
territorios palestinos así tal vez lo
más destacable sea la primera mención de
bailén durante su viaje sobre jiri novak
le pese a errar la pronunciación de su
apellido dijo que la periodista
asesinada también es una pérdida para
eeuu y que persistirán en la
investigación de su crimen un pequeño
grupo de manifestantes
con el lema las vidas palestinas
importan recordó a la reportera en las
afueras del hospital la gusta victoria
de jerusalén este al que byd en acudió
antes de su reunión con abbas esta fue
la primera visita de un presidente
estadounidense a un barrio de mayoría
palestina en jerusalén esté fuera de la
ciudad vieja un hito al que va a ir en
su mal primer viaje directo de israel a
arabia saudita el reino su última parada
y una de sus misiones que se acercarlo a
israel ha empezado con buen pie luego de
que riad abriera el espacio aéreo a
vuelos desde y hacia israel este primer
acercamiento podría sumar vuelos
especiales para peregrinos musulmanes
pero una normalización de las relaciones
como la que israel ya tiene con emiratos
árabes o bahrein nos espera en un corto
plazo